where you're like it's nice to sit here
when you're doing like craig you know
like crazy amounts of of interviews like
around the world and oh yeah like oh
it's nice that because they have that
day where you you get that list of like
times
that's the worst day of anyone's life
because it goes from like
6 a.m to like 11 and it's just these all
these numbers you have to call and
they're six minutes each yeah sometimes
they put you on they just keep sending
people in
and people don't understand that people
like say will smith
like twice a year three times a year he
has to sit in rooms for like a month and
talk to someone every six minutes
oh my god and the fact that it hasn't
broken their spirit
yeah yeah that's why i hate when you see
like you know they they give like they
make gifts out of uh what's that dude
not matt damon the other one that
happened
is that his name or his reactions
but you see like sometimes in his
interview they give moments of him
either falling asleep or he's lost hope
yeah i like that having an existential
meltdown and and you probably could do
that honestly to any
person all right right like if you had
the raw footage
of all of don cheadle doing a press
junket there'd be a moment where he'd be
like oh god yeah why am i alive there's
something there's a when i see photos of
ben affleck there's one photo of him
outside his house or something he's
leaning against a wall and he has a
cigarette and he's kind of slouched yeah
that photo i wish i had that photo
earlier on in my career
because i in my mind in my head i'm like
once i get all those things
right everything's solved this one yeah
that one you want you're no no and what
if i was a young man and i saw that i'd
be like you know what dude enjoy today
but you know what isn't it
you know the essence of life like
that that photo is like the mona lisa
i think so too because people don't
understand
you know
everyone's life is stressful and you
think oh you know he's running around
the world and he's with j.lo and he's
batman for a period but really that's
how he feels
which is which is how we feel yeah you
know at the end of the day that's old
and he had to walk like imagine that
walk he's just grabbing the cigarette
and just
i guess i have to smoke outside
i just need a minute and then he can't
even be left alone like yeah
photographing his one nose they're
taking photos like [ __ ] it
take the photo [ __ ] it yeah i mean it
was take that off man it's too good
looking to look at
so did you do a lot of writing in the
pandemic well what happened was i
so i had to promote the movie and they
put the movie where you could like buy
it online we were supposed to be in the
theater yeah and we were like you know
should we just you know put it online
now and it felt like
there's kind of nothing to watch and
everyone's so depressed and we have a
funny hopefully sweet movie it would be
weird to not give it to people now it
seems like it's for now so it felt nice
to have something to offer up people
even if it was just two hours of a break
and then i
i really felt like i'm either gonna gain
like 40 pounds
and be drunk for the next year yeah
or i have to get healthy like it's not
going to be in the middle
yeah yeah it's not you know like i
normally live in the middle yeah yeah
but uh where you're growing a little
little shitty like i'm kind of into
shape and out of shape like i work out a
little i eat shitty half the time you
know that can i make it i have an
observation about you yes please did you
gain a little or lose weight i can't
tell well i'll tell you because it's
okay it says everything about
excuse me i've been sick three times
in the last month with non-coveted
diseases
so are there are we really other
diseases yeah i've had every other
disease but
wow last six weeks so flu you had yeah
so i'll have a haunting cough but it's
like
a different thing yeah um so i lost 15
pounds i was walking